olá bom dia pessoal
meus amigos estão assistindo maneira
limpa para alguns deles nem ele deve
estar dizendo assim o ted talks virou
stand up comedy neto daniel fala de
futebol não funciona
na verdade eu vou falar aquele futebol
tradicional que vocês estão acostumados
a ver ou falar de um outro futebol mas a
minha história começa eu achei legal
porque hoje pela manhã várias histórias
começaram com essa questão da família
minha história também começa com a
família
a emissora começa na contra capa de um
livro chamado fernão capelo gaivota que
eu ganhei quando tinha seis anos de
idade do meu pai
neste livro o meu pai dizia o seguinte
né e dizer que eu deveria assim como
fernão capelo gaivota livro voar mais
alto e voar mais rápido nem sempre
desafiando o status quo das coisas
sempre sendo uma pessoa inquieta
mas uma coisa importante daquela frase
que ele colocou os seguintes faça isso
mas sempre respeitando as pessoas nem
sempre respeitando os seus valores e aí
eu comecei a me desenvolver lá pelos
início dos 90
não é pra eu entregar um pouco minha
idade mas quando estava na adolescência
e aquele início dos 90 o momento
político meio estranho no brasil né
aí eu comecei já com uma uma atividade
mais crítica de porque as coisas são
assim né porque as pessoas não respeitam
e nesse momento eu me lembro que tinha
um pai de uma namorada minha que me
disse o seguinte né
agora que você é adolescente é você tem
energia e vai querer lutar e transformar
as coisas mas quando você crescer não é
ficar mais velho de uma família
você vai perder essa energia vai fazer a
vou ficar me acomodar aqui e vou ver
como é que as coisas acontecem ea
resposta que eu tenho que dar pra ele
hoje eu não me acomodei é por isso que
estou aqui neste palco hoje
então eu vou contar uma história pra
vocês sobre os valores nessa quem somos
nós seja a oposição aqueles valores que
a gente aprende desde criança a respeito
amor né
e assim por diante e como é que nós
aprendemos isso e como é que o futebol
pode ser uma ferramenta para ajudar a
ensinar esses valores
eu acabo de ter um filho não é meu filho
tem um ano e um pouquinho nicolas e
engraçado porque agora eu tô tendo o
papel de pai
assim como o pai teve é eu começo a ver
como é que ele aprende as coisas e às
vezes ele está sentado na cadeira dele
joga as coisas no chão e você fala não
isso é certo isso é errado e você começa
a ensinar um pouco dessa história dos
valores do filho e aí ele joga de novo e
ele joga de novo ele joga de novo porque
ele está aprendendo ele está testando
ele está entendendo até mesmo às vezes
não está bem e querendo entender se
aquilo é certo e errado ele gostou do
som e aquilo faz colocar no chão
então esse aprendizado que a gente vai
tendo desde criança e que depois a gente
viu aí a professora falando também que a
gente as professoras minha mãe também
foi professora pública nem a minha mãe
fez um papel muito com certeza muito
grande em termos de ensinar valores e
tenho certeza que ela fez também
ensinando valores aos seus alunos é é é
dessa forma que a gente vai crescendo e
vai aprender os valores agora pessoal
imaginem o quanto as pessoas nesse
planeta não tem essa estrutura não tem
essa estrutura familiar que te ensina
valores que não têm acesso a professores
não têm acesso à escola
porém motivos motivos econômicos motivos
sociais ou motivos até mesmo de guerra
situações onde as pessoas ficam
completamente fora de si
nesse ambiente e aí começa a história
desse futebol né
veja como é que eu posso usar esse
futebol para ensinar valores para as
pessoas e para contar essa história que
ele voltar um pouco no tempo voltar um
pouco no tempo
na copa de 1994 lembra laura galvão
bueno até é aquela coisa todo mundo né
naquele mesmo momento é que eu comentei
início dos anos 90 ela mesmo o
conturbado politicamente nessa copa do
mundo grande que grande parte de vocês
lembra desse momento é da passa o mundo
feliz e tudo mais mas garante que pouco
de vocês devem lembrar desse outro
momento aqui o nome desse cara chamado
andrés escobar
ele é um zagueiro da colômbia ea
colômbia nesse nessa época vivia um
momento também conturbado em relação às
drogas deve lembrar que os estados
unidos
tentando intervir e ajudar né pra
reduzir a questão de tráfico de drogas
da colômbia andrés escobar um jogo
contra os estados unidos faz um gol
contra e todo mundo na colômbia ficou p
da vida na época o mercado faz um gol
contra e ele antes de ir embora da copa
da da copa do mundo quer nos estados
unidos
ele manda uma carta para o povo
colombiano pediu desculpa e ele diz o
seguinte é que um gol não pode valer uma
vida e rat acontece a gente tem que
aprender com os erros e seguir adiante e
ele queria disse mais na casa deles é o
seguinte ele disse que ele aprendeu
muito naquele momento de copa do mundo
hoje é um momento de confraternização
onde vários países estavam juntos e
aprendendo com o evento
só que essa história não foi muito feliz
no final ele voltou pra colômbia e ao
sair numa uma noite uma casa noturna no
estacionamento ele foi assassinado neste
mesmo momento na colômbia vive esse cara
william ury ele fazia terminava o seu o
seu doutorado na colômbia vai fazer uma
tese ele viu isso acontecer e falou o
seguinte poxa realmente assim como o o o
andrés falou
o futebol não pode valer uma vida o
futebol tem que ser mais do que isso ele
acaba no final de contas sendo uma
ferramenta que pode chegar a alguns
lugares mais remotos do planeta porque
todo mundo gosta de futebol enquanto os
vídeos a gente assiste
aí quando se fala em futebol e tem
aquela vila no meio àquela localidade
remota e falar o pessoal com uma bolinha
feita de de 6 jogando futebol
ele tem uma brilhante idéia de criar uma
organização não governamental e
transformar um pouquinho e se essa
história do futebol
e aí que eu me identifiquei com essa
história não é tipo poxa meu pai tinha
dito desafio status corro né
totó transforma as coisas esse cara fez
exatamente isso que diz o seguinte o
futebol tem que ser jogado só dessa
forma não dá pra jogar um pouquinho
diferente e fazer algo a mais e esse
cara da organização dele e chama escrito
ou outro ele criou uma forma onde ele
chamou de futebol 3
mas futebol funciona eu tenho um
primeiro tempo onde as as pessoas as
crianças sejam adolescentes quem quer
que seja é das suas trabalho das
organizações não governamentais pelo
mundo estão fazendo então você senta com
esse grupo de pessoas e você discute e
cria regras de fair play ou seja do tipo
ah se alguém fizer uma falta eu não
posso continuar o jogo tem que parar o
jogo e ajudar a pessoa a levantar se
tiver menina jogando com meninos e as
meninas obrigatoriamente tem que passar
a aposta em passar por elas antes de ser
feito um louco isso tudo acaba levando
as pessoas a a aprender valores que
aquela estrutura tradicional que deveria
ensinar esses valores acaba han ensina
através do futebol porque três tempos
porque o tempo do meio obviamente em
jogar futebol
a gente joga curte né esse fator esse
processo só que enquanto se jogando esse
futebol existe uma facilitador de uma
organização não governamental está
cuidando desse grupo de crianças e
adolescentes
ele captura esses dados com ele captura
todas as informações e hoje ele captura
naquele papel não é só com uma foto de
uma das nomeações governamentais de
israel que usa essa metodologia e
instalar aparelhos em e que no final o
terceiro tempo de futebol
basicamente quando você senta de novo
com as crianças explica pra eles
tudo que aconteceu no jogo e discutir
lembra aquela que no momento que a
pessoa né fez a falta você não continuam
não parou para ajudar ela você continuou
e aí todos os valores de de fair play e
valores que a gente aprendeu e aprendi a
todo momento na sociedade e as pessoas
são privadas muitas vezes disso você
acaba aprendendo nessa metodologia
esse cara tem uma grande idéia nessa
hoje a organização nem lícito hoje é
muito maior não só falando disso porém
começou lá em 94 ele teve a idéia de
seguinte o coxa
vamos usar a tecnologia para ajudar isso
e ele chamou a essa pequena empresa que
trabalho aqui é uma empresa alemã de
software é uma empresa de software de
gestão alemã
lá em berlim ele será o seguinte vamos
fazer um campeonato né a lembrando um
detalhe é essa que tinha que lembrar
esses caras da alemanha sabiam muito
mais de futebol do que daniel e eles
foram culpados por aquele tal de 7 a 11
a gente levou na copa do mundo o
software de performance atlética a
seleção da alemanha usou na copa do
mundo era fornecido também por essa pela
pela total de sp
mas o que eles falam seguinte poxa vamos
fazer um campeonato bom pegar pessoas de
vários lugares do mundo
desenvolvedores vão pegar várias
organizações não governamentais de
vários lugares do mundo e vamos criar
uma aplicação que eu possa ajudar esse
processo do futebol 3 ea indiferença
essa competição
essa competição ela aconteceu em seis
países e o primeiro país é de recuo foi
brasil no país do futebol vão fazer lá
no brasil e eu contei um time dentro da
do laboratório o trabalho de alguns
provedores amigos que gostavam e
participei como um dos competidores cada
país tinha aproximadamente dez equipes
participando e eu perdi o time não foi
bem em ganhasse iria pra lyon aparenta
apresentar um evento que tem todo ano do
instituto o outro é esse a solução para
o ministro da educação da frança e mais
1 22 países
eu perdi mas eu perdi pelo seguinte
motivo lembra que a história dos valores
nem o que é certo é certo e errado é
errado
uma das normas que fundados no início do
campeonato é o seguinte a solução
apresentada no final não pode ser um
mockup não pode ser uma alguma casca tem
que ser um aplicativo funcional e eu
dediquei meu time e fiz isso até o
último minuto pra chegar nesse estágio
só pela competição de três dias àquele
sacar tons loucos de ficar de madrugada
trabalhando mais
eu não consegui chegar num estágio mesmo
quando chegaram e um outro time ganhou
com o canto
adivinha o chato aqui que têm valores
muito muito enraizadas foi reformado
bateu na porta e falou o seguinte ó isso
aqui não pode funcionar sim eu sei que
aí by the way
eu acho que nós não deveríamos fazer
isso no modelo de competição faz
deveríamos fazer isso no modelo
colaborativo
porque eu já competi fazer um aplicativo
aqui competindo o aplicativo dos estados
unidos com o aplicativo da índia porque
a gente vai perder energia vai perdendo
o poder da colaboração e da gente poder
se ajudar e aí toma né
foi reclamar tão presente pra você e aí
pessoal eles me deram um desafio pra mim
foi um desafio dos profissionais mais
importantes da minha vida que foi o
seguinte colocar seis países dentro de
uma sala e através de uma metodologia
criativa chamada design thinking fazer
com que eles chegassem em um único
aplicativo
nós estamos falando aqui para o pessoal
de países por exemplo estou falando de
israel palestina estados unidos alemanha
hungria índia e brasil e uma mesma sala
não é fácil cada um tem suas
necessidades sociais cada país tem sua
realidade por exemplo o palestino
israelense usa esse método para ensinar
valores para que as crianças de ambos os
povos para que parem de brigar
enquanto nós estamos ensinando os
valores para tirar as crianças das ruas
e que elas sejam melhores a adultos
melhores seres humanos no futuro
então isso foi um grande desafio que nós
fizemos nós iríamos fazer esse desafio
em três dias apenas nós tínhamos três
dias com esse grupo todo de de pessoas
eram 150 desenvolvedores mais 150
adolescentes ou crianças de organizações
não governamentais desses seis países
sentado nessa sala no final nós chegamos
a uma solução onde a gente consegue
ajudar basicamente 5 públicos
o jogador é que as crianças e
adolescentes
o facilitador que faz toda aquela gestão
desse esse processo do futebol 3
as organizações não governamentais
instituto boa fé
ele teve essa idéia e patrocinadores
lembrando pessoal eu já fiz várias vezes
isso não é às vezes vem uma campanha é
de doação e tudo mais
e quando vocês vão pensar duas três
vezes porque o boto meu dinheiro aqui
será que o faça a doação será que
realmente está chegando aonde deveria
chegar a gente tem essas dúvidas afinal
de contas pessoas que aprenderam os seus
valores no passado às vezes durante o
caminho da vida se esquece e quantas
vezes a gente está vendo isso é só uma
roubadinha no senado é só uma roubadinha
ali a tranqüilo é mais valores são
valores então um dos objetivos nossos
com esta aplicação e aquilo que mostrar
só algumas
algumas telas para vocês a gente fez um
estilo bem né fácil de utilizar aquelas
coisas tipo b você pode descobrir onde
os jogos se acompanha a performance é o
facilitador a performance desses desses
jogadores dessas crianças e adolescentes
eu tenho uma papa plataforma onde eu
posso mensurar aqueles pontos por fair
play as regras de fair-play quebradas e
também mensurar
obviamente a qualidade como jogador
estou requisitos norte americano ele
falar o seguinte aqui nos estados unidos
um bom jogador eu consigo tirar das ruas
eu consigo uma bolsa numa universidade
quantas vezes você não escutar aquelas
histórias né ao karaté estou agora numa
super a universidade porque é um bom
esportista
então ele conseguiu combinar todos os
requisitos de todos os lugares do mundo
em uma única a solução e no final essa
grande camada em que construiu no final
uma camada analítica que dava justamente
essa transparência para impor o
patrocinador e para os gestores das
organizações governamentais para
entender quando as crianças estão
atingindo como o dinheiro está sendo
distribuído criando algo similar a uma
rede
então esse basicamente foi o objetivo
dessa história e dessa forma como eu me
engajei então aquela coisa de às vezes o
cara falou aquilo você quando você
crescer você vai se acalmar e não vai
lutar pelo que é certo ou errado eu tô
lutando a minha forma
da mesma forma que eu posso né com os
recursos que eu tenho minha janta em
tipo de se decidir
judith atividade então a mensagem que eu
queria deixar para vocês é que se
engajem façam um pouquinho cada um na de
alguma forma e que a gente vai conseguir
chegar e ajudar esse grande população do
mundo só pra finalizar nós apresentamos
aqui para 22 países e um dos dons dos
feedbacks a gente percebeu que foi um
dos que mais me comoveu foi de uma
pessoa com quem eu estava na platéia e
ela cuida dessas crianças no quênia
ela disse daniel essa ferramenta vai
conseguir dar visibilidade a essas
crianças que o trabalho e não sei se
você sabe mas no quênia em comunidades
onde o trabalho as crianças aparecem às
vezes são assassinadas
ninguém se preocupa com elas são apenas
algo está ali mas com isso eu vou
conseguir monitorar cada uma
se ela não vier no treino já sei eu não
venho começar a agir e assim por diante
a sua história eu queria contar pra
vocês desse engajamento ea transformação
social e desse protagonismo todo era a
história do que quer
bom muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]